genetic counselors in Boston are
offering parents a controversial glimpse
into the future of their baby's health
it's part of a landmark study that could
lead to gene scans for all newborns by
law every child in the u.s. gets a blood
test for about 30 conditions including
cystic fibrosis and sickle cell anemia
the trial at Brigham and Women's
Hospital uses genomic genomic sequencing
to screen for about 1,800 conditions
including some cancers Toni Tecopa
visited the researchers and joins us now
Toni good morning good morning by
testing babies long before they show
symptoms doctors hope to start treatment
early that could save lives and prevent
suffering but it also raises questions
of privacy and discrimination and that's
a major reason why most families are
still saying no thanks
Medusa is it a flower the day after
their daughter Cora was born Loren
Stetson and her husband Kyle got an
unexpected visit from a genetic
counselor I was in full recovery mode as
in I don't care about anything I'm just
trying to keep our baby alive and
recover myself the visitor offered a
free DNA scan for Cora a scan that the
Stetsons learned could reveal
disease-causing variations in their
daughter's genetic code I was just
trying to make it through the day so
that was definitely something that was a
little shocking baby Cora is now one of
the first healthy kids in America to
have had her genome searched for hidden
problems doctors found a partial biotin
ADIZ deficiency something that Cora
showed no outward signs of having had it
not been detected it could have caused a
permanent drop in her IQ it's a pretty
insane thing to think about she would
have still been considered normal nobody
would have identified her as diseased
dr. Robert Greene is a medical
geneticist at Harvard and co-director of
the baby seat project which enrolled
Cora and is now recruiting hundreds of
other families so you could potentially
save a child's life absolutely but dr.
green is also warning families about the
risks including breaches of privacy and
genetic discrimination we can't predict
what
discrimination is going to be occurring
by the time your child grows up we can't
predict whether there's some sort of
privacy breaches and this information
gets out and is used against your child
in some sort of future scenario and we
most importantly we can't predict the
informations accurate many genetic
variations turn out to be harmless and
even if not most of the conditions dr.
greens team is looking for still have no
cure what makes you comfortable
telling people about illnesses they
can't treat I would have to say I'm not
100% comfortable with it what we're
really trying to do in this study is ask
the question how beneficial or harmful
is it to go down this road
baby Cora is beating her condition
thanks to a daily vitamin mixed into
some yogurt like supermom so you're
talking extended family members and yet
about nine out of ten families
approached by dr. Greene and his team
have declined the testing people are
distrustful of information gathering
they're just they're hearing about all
these break-ins and hacks and I'm afraid
a lot of people are turning down the
possibility of this information at this
time because they just don't trust the
future but dr. green believes the fear
is temporary and before long most
Americans will feel much like the
Stetsons do already I always think that
more knowledge is power and so anyone
who is wavering I think even though the
results may be scary I think it's more
scary to play the guessing game and now
you want to get your son tested or I
would love to do that the baby seek
program is part of a twenty five million
dollar effort funded by the National
Institute of Health the genetic data
collected will be housed in an academic
molecular lab and participants do
consent to having it uploaded to a
federal database for possible future
research the first results of this
current study are expected in the next
couple of years and will help doctors
and lawmakers importantly decide how to
use this technology responsibly I think
this is clearly the future here well the
dilemma though is still the breaches of
privacy and genetic discrimination I
think that that's what most people are
concerned also free will I don't want to
be a law
but my DNA sequence says I want to be
you know it's sort of like at what point
to do you begin to predict the future
and what point are you coaxing it into
existence almost it's such a personal
decision to for these families but
you're right it is absolutely the future
I don't know how you close Pandora's Box
at this point this is it this is coming
all right so we need a couple thank you
very much Tony